[Background voices] DR. ARTHUR MUTAMBARA >> Hi,
YouTube. My name is Arthur Mutambara, one
of the opposing leaders from Zimbabwe. I am
here in Davos attending the world economic
forum about the young global leaders.
On thing that companies, countries and individuals
have to do differently is the way they understand
the nature of global challenges and the way
they develop and construct solutions to those
challenges. We live in a very interdependent
world where global challenges are interconnected.
Climate change, globalization, poverty, human
rights, HIV Aids-they're interconnected and
hence we need their wholistic and inclusive
understanding of those global challenges,
such that you can't serve the globe around
climate change for America. We're done addressing
poverty, HIV Aids and governance issuesin
Africa. As you address climate change, as
you try to address terrorism, you must address
the grievances of the poor. You must address
challenges of HIV Aids in a wholistic and
inclusive approach to creating solutions to
global challenges.
For example, more specifically, the world
must take a vested interest approach for the
crisis in Zimbabwe. Because an injustice any
way is an injustice every way.
There will be only one kind of victory-global
victory-for the human race in one planet.
We are in this fight and this trouble together.